louis pugh has completed a 7.8 kilometer
swim in greenland's elulasat ice fjord i
think i probably got the pronunciation
of that wrong he tackled waters clogged
with pieces of ice to highlight the
melting of the greenland ice sheet as
part of his calls for 30 of the world's
oceans to be protected by 2030. uh let's
speak to the man mad enough to do it at
lewisview joins us once again on the
channel lewis always lovely to see you
and and i'm afraid i have to start as i
always seem to do when interviewing you
with with two very simple questions why
and what possibly possessed you
uh thank you so much and you did get the
pronunciation right it's called the
alulas at icefield it's on western
greenland and the lulasat is an inuit
name for the place of big icebergs and
certainly that was the case
the reason why i went to do it was very
very simple i swim in some of the most
vulnerable ecosystems in the world to
highlight what's happening there
in a lula set now it's the fastest
moving glacier in the world it's now
moving at a speed of 40 meters per day
in summer and so this was a swim in the
month now before the big climate change
negotiations which take place in glasgow
to highlight the speed and the scale of
the climate crisis
and we will dwell on that in just a
second but just in terms of the
practicalities surrounding a swim like
that lewis we've just been looking at
pictures of you there you know clouds in
the traditional budgie smugglers rather
than a dry suit or even a wetsuit how
are you able to cope with the
temperatures where they are
well i mean i
spent nearly 18 years swimming in the
polar regions so there's a lot of
experience that goes into it before i
get into the water i get slowly into the
water so that i don't hyperventilate and
then i swim as fast as i can but it's
been years and years of experience and
years and years of acclimatization to be
able to get into these freezing cold
waters
when i do the swim so this swim was a
multi-day swim
it was 12 swims
apologies 14 swims over a period of 12
days
i swim in the morning i then have to
rewarm i then so many afternoons so just
it really was unrelenting though by far
the hardest swim i have ever undertaken
in my life
um so tell us then just a little bit
more more about about uh the illusion
glacier i mean the the pictures from
your swimmer are stunning but this is an
area i suspect which needs some very
very careful con careful concern over
the next few years if we're to avoid
disastrous outcomes
yes absolutely i mean i've never seen
anything like it on day two of the
expedition so just to explain the the
the glacier is at the top of a long
field the field is about 60 kilometers
long and at the mouth of the field there
are a number of huge icebergs these
icebergs are about a kilometer tall it's
unbelievable
um and during the swim one of these
dislodged and behind it were literally
thousands and thousands and thousands of
smaller icebergs and i've never seen
anything like it because it was like a
motorway of ice ice coming off the
greenland ice sheet
down the glacier
into the field and then
it was like as i say a motorway of ice
going all the way out 10 kilometers out
to sea
a very timely reminder that we cannot
negotiate with the climate so what is
happening now uh and as i as i said
earlier this glacier is now moving at a
speed of 40 kilometers per uh per day
um
it was very very worrying to see it
first hand and also to go up onto the
green and ice sheet and see lots and
lots of what we call glacial lakes so
these are melt water lakes which are now
appearing on top of the ice sheet
just tell us about a little bit more
lewis about the importance of large ice
masses
like this one i think most people will
be aware of the prospect of you know the
ice melting and the seas rising but it's
about more than that isn't it
i mean ice is essential for life on
earth
i say to people no ice no life it's
essential for life on earth because ice
keeps our planet within a temperature
range in which we can live and so now as
the arctic is beginning to melt and down
in the southern hemisphere as antarctica
is also uh melting and also the glaciers
on the high mountains of the world
this has a huge impact on us all over
the world so what's happening now in a
lula set
will literally impact every single
person on this planet every future
generation and the whole of the animal
kingdom
when it comes to the glaciers on the
mountains
these glaciers provide a constant water
supply
to villages towns cities all the way
downstream so obviously
ice is essential
it's as important as the air we breathe
okay and unless we get a grip on this
climate crisis unless we're able to turn
this ship around and get all the world
leaders now who are meeting at the end
of the year in glasgow
to take action we've had 27 years now of
negotiations
think about that 27 years of
negotiations
um unless we're able to get them to make
firm commitments and take action today
that
if if we can't get that
then our our future is
is is is very bleak
louis in your mind then given that which
you've seen well at the the ice fjord
and on all your trips around the world
is the damage that has been done to the
planet reversible or is the campaign as
much as anything else about slowing the
rate of damage that we're doing to our
world
i mean that's certainly a question which
a climate scientist would would be able
to answer i'm a maritime lawyer with
respect but certainly from what i what
i've been seeing now the speed of this
uh melt
every single year i'm seeing it getting
faster and faster when i did my first
swim in the arctic
in 2003 the sea ice was three degree i
mean the the the water temperature was
three degrees centigrade
i went back there 12 years later and the
water was in the arctic was no longer
three degrees centigrade it had risen to
10 degrees centigrade
so it gone from three to ten in just 12
years north of the island of spitzbergen
so this is right on the edge of the
arctic
uh
sea ice
that's the speed at which this is
happening
a huge amount of significance and
importance therefore
to be placed in the [ __ ] 26 meeting
later this year
yes
196 nations will be meeting their
business leaders will be coming there
civil society will be coming there my
message for all of them is we need to
take action today we cannot kick this
can down the road any longer